he loved actors he really loved him and
he was and he had his way of directing
sometimes was like for example when we
did the scene at Christmas morning when
raucous in his cups and he wants to give
me the ranch and I've been drafted he
called me into the rocks dressing room
and rock was there with a glass of
scotch
8:00 the morning but was the rock wasn't
a drinkers but but Rock wanted to feel
like he was a drinker in the scene and I
think he just felt a little insecure
about that so George was I sat down I'm
sitting on the couch and and suddenly
George starts talking and to himself and
he says whatever there's no son of a
[ __ ] once yeah and I suddenly realized
that's one of the way George directs he
he would become you he played you he
would play the care if he didn't tell
you what to do he would kind of show you
what to do many times that's I noticed
that he was doing that with actors it
was wonderful and all the time we did
that scene we must he covered it must
have covered it from every conceivable
angle including from the back of our
heads yeah I think that James Dean
referred to George Stevens directing
style as the around-the-clock style
since he would shoot it from every
conceivable angle all around yeah he
always did but but you know he ends up
with well anyway while every time we did
the scene and I would mention being
drafted off-camera I would hear him
snickering you know he was a real
audience he's sitting there snickering
so even though I was afraid it was a
little a little bit over the top but
George seemed to like it so we just kept
doing it over okay tell us a little bit
about what the atmosphere was like on
the set you were talking about that when
we were in the well first of all we went
down the second generation went down
they'd been there for a couple of weeks
or three weeks or whatever it was and
and the second generation of actors went
down on the train this is to Marfa Texas
the Marfa Texas yes to Marfa Texas and
Dennis Hopper Alma put in the same
stateroom little did I know we were also
going to share the same bedroom for the
next you know month and a half because
in those days you know as a supporting
actor
you rarely got a room to yourself on
location you always shared it with
somebody and I had some dealings I
shared one within Brooke bra and the
British local Reid with Mickey Rooney
and then working a lot with the broken
glass with Hugh O'Brien I shared one
with a destination goby with Ross
Bagdasarian who later wrote well come on
in my house so it wrote the Alfred the
Chipmunks songs yeah but anyway it's a
real honor to be here with someone that
spent the night with Alvin listen Mickey
Rooney was more fun maybe Mickey Rooney
and Alvin should have you know well well
Mickey Rooney thought he was without me
yeah we won't get into that anyway where
was I
you were talking about the atmosphere in
the set about yeah well anyway yes
around the clock with Ruth but but you
know he ended up Oh George loved to
shoot George's George's dream was to
work in the cutting room
he once said if he had to give up
directing or acting or I mean directing
acting producing writing or whatever he
said the one thing he would keep would
be anything that that was the one thing
that he would give up directing he said
for editing he loved it he had thousands
literally thousands of feet of film of
when they get miles of film at the end
of June and he spent a year cutting it
he loved to find little things in the in
the cutting room when he was doing Shane
for example he had the shot above
Shane's horse behind the barn in the
corral munching on grass and no with his
head up and then he goes down much his
own grass and when he's runs it when he
runs it back and forth on the movie Ola
suddenly that horse is not as much in
grabs Nate's head goes up like that and
George takes that clip reverses it like
that and then lays Brenda Brandon do
willed his voice in the morning a little
laugh coming in and he was so delighted
that he just quit and that was it for
the day he loved he loved that he'd
discovered that little moment there I
think this is a good moment to
acknowledge the editor of this film
William Hornbeck who was a legendary and
writer write and he edited this as well
as one of
Oscar for place in the Sun and did an
incredible job
also William L or the cinematographer
who worked with George Stevens and of
course the marvelous square by Dmitry T
Hogan and what
but the marvelous core music by Dmitri
oh he died in 1975 I just discovered
yeah incredible score he had a
tremendous crew of people who worked but
he was one of the guys that George
Eisenhower doing the war chose Georgia
to head up the the military of cinema
cinema graphic yes group he found a big
group to take overseas to film the end
of the war and the battles and also to
go into the concentration camps and
that's what really changed we had such
an effect on George from that on he quit
doing comedies for so long and really
got serious about he wanted in fact he
said about this picture you want to do
something you know with that people
could get you know into and and really
yeah to really make people think and
start to change the world which yeah the
film definitely did but you mentioned
they said well what joy George did a
brilliant thing you know the Texans
hated hated the book giant hated it and
they they really there was George had a
hell of a time getting a studio to
produce it finally Jack Warner agreed to
but only if George would take not a cent
for the movie he worked for like three
years writing the script working and
producing the whole it took about three
years out of his life he did not get a
penny for any of that he did have a
piece of the picture at the end if it
was a success but he also had the main
thing he had was control and he insisted
on having the final cut and at the end
of it there's a scene in the movie by
the way where they thanked out by the
pool that new pool and they thank the
senator played by Charlie Watts
for helping them to get this oil
depletion tax between seven and a half
percent tax of some of the pollution
it's a big deal for the oil man food
through the government and Bob O'Donnell
who had two or three hundred theaters in
Texas
big big big man if you didn't play his
theaters you didn't
you weren't playing Texas and if he
called the studio when he found out
about this scene and and demanded that
Jack Warner take that scene out of the
film well Jack Warner went it to George
Stephenson and said you have to take
this edge George says I have final cut
Jack and will not take it out of the
film he begged him went back he came
back again came back twice and begged
him to think that George held his ground
and would not take it out it's in there
today it never took it out but he said
if dump if Bob O'Donnell doesn't run
this film and is in Texas we're not we
don't stand a chance of making the money
back but they did when they opened it in
Texas it was a huge hit a huge hit I
mean it was broke all kinds of records I
mean the Texans loved it they didn't
like the book but they loved the movie